i kind of have a second talk of the
table here it is oprah winfrey's latest
selection for her book club she is
making the announcement only on cbs
mornings take a listen
cbs mornings team everybody i'm so
excited to present my next book club
selection from the pulitzer
award-winning richard powers his latest
book bewilderment
and it is good people the book tells the
story of a widowed father theo and his
son robin who faces behavioral issues
neurodivergent is the word for it it
also describes a planet in peril and
robin's particular link to it he's a
very interesting kid richard power is
also interesting author won the pulitzer
prize for his 2018 novel overstory and
we had the opportunity to sit down with
oprah and the author to discuss the
inspiration for this latest novel and
also bigger picture our connections to
this planet and beyond
so you've won a pulitzer prize a
national book award a macarthur genius
grant but now you can add to that list
that you are an oprah book club
selection i think that's some sort of
literary egot
well i certainly put this thrill
alongside the the greatest ones of my
career and i've been writing for 40
years the book tells the story of a
young boy named robin an exceptional and
exceptionally charming young man
tell me when that character
spoke to you i had started this book
with a different
cast of characters in mind and
i was toying with
a sort of tone and approach that just
wasn't working for me
and when i get stymied when i hit the
wall what i like to do more than
anything else is is to walk and i was
maybe three or four miles down
one of my favorite trails in the park
and i had this odd sensation
that there was a weight on my shoulders
and i thought there's there's a little
boy sitting on my back like i often see
on the trails with you know fathers
carrying their their kids after their
kids can't take another step i imagined
this boy kind of clamoring down and
walking alongside me on the trail and i
thought who is this guy and
it wasn't until i was heading back up
the trail uh to the trailhead that i
realized that's who my story is about
it's why writers are my rock stars i
always love hearing the story that's why
i'm so glad you asked that question tony
of how this came to be
of how the visitation or the vision or
how these characters show up in their
lives the book is kind of an indictment
of us here on planet earth that we've
lost our empathy
and we need it rebuilt somehow
so the book the book is dark but it's
also i think an exploration
of just how lucky and rich this world
still is
and it's trying to tell a story about
how we might find our way back to it
yeah i think the way we find our way
back to it is contained in something
that little robin says in the book which
is that everyone
is in everyone ultimately
one of the reasons why i love the book
so much is because it does exactly that
lets us see how separated we are and
allows us to think tony about how do we
start to get back to ourselves and to
each other
so the book touches on something called
the fermi paradox which is
simply put the question if life is out
there in the universe
where is it why haven't we been visited
and it makes me
want to ask you the question are we
alone
i would say
that we certainly aren't alone
i don't think we're ever going to get a
signal anytime soon
from anything that looks or sounds or
would be understandable to us
but i think life fills the universe i
think the universe wants life but
meanwhile as i hike around the smokies
all my reading and thinking about life
out there has made me realize that there
is alien life and it's all over and we
just have to stand still and be present
to it
i believe
that there's life
everywhere and just because we cannot
articulated for ourselves and relate to
it in the way that we see things but
more importantly i think
one of the things that this book and
overstory certainly did was change the
way i live on the planet and i see the
life around me
differently and experience it
differently that which would have been
alien to me or that which would have
been like oh that's just nature or
whatever i now see that as a part of the
life that is all of us and the earth is
still
fierce and powerful and full you know
this world is a lucky place
i agree completely in fact i'm going to
go for a hike i'll see you guys later
oprah enjoy the rest of your afternoon
richard good luck getting home okay see
you guys
yeah yeah the book is bewilderment it's
on sale wherever you like to buy your
books it will change the way you view
nature and it will make you want to go
on a hike it's gorgeous yeah that's what
oprah says listen she has always been
very in tuned and very much in love with
nature but she said this this made her
see things at a totally different level
that even she hadn't paid attention to
before and as i said she's very plugged
in and very tuned and by the way richard
powers mentioned the smokies he's
talking about the great smoky mountains
yeah the book is set it's also where he
lives he calls it the most beautiful
place on earth it wasn't it wasn't
something just to get him to come down
for the interview yeah he lives way up
there uh no internet uh service like we
needed uh so he had to go somewhere
special for it so
how much of a disconnect there is until
we are still and we just sit and
experience what nature really provides
for us yeah all of us should take a
minute totally still
no doubt about it